Would it hurt to define of what a
religious experiences in this case then?
Because I feel like the semantics of like,
I'm not sure if what you're saying
about a religious experience is what I'm
understanding.
Well,
generally a religious experience is
something like an experience of the,
of the renewal of the world.
That might be one way of,
of thinking about it so that everything's
sort of leaps forward as crystal clean
and perfect as if you had been viewing
it from behind the mask before.
Another would be a sense
of the Union of everything.
And so you're a singular being and you're
isolated and in religious experiences.
So for example,
there's a book written
recently by a neuroscientist,
uh,
my stroke of,
what's it called?
My stroke of insight.
Yeah,
that's right.
And I believe she had a
left hemisphere stroke,
if I remember correctly.
And she was
sufficiently well developed
neuroscientists to understand
what was happening as
she had the stroke.
And,
and she had a intense religious
experience as a consequence of that.
And she experienced it as a dissolution
of the ego into this state of union with
everything.
And this transcendent
experience of awe and and the,
oh well I don't remember the rest of it.
I mean there are other elements
of religious experience
that are quite common.
The idea of the opening of the heavens,
that's one.
The communion with the ancestors,
that's another the reduction
of the body to a skeleton,
that's another the movement
up into heaven there.
These are well documented phenomena
and a lot of them are associated.
While a fair number of them are
associated with psychedelic use,
but that's not the only
avenue to experiences like
that and epilepsy can produce
experiences like that too and people
usually report near death experiences as
well.
And you know,
people usually report that
those experiences have
life altering significance.
Now that in and of itself only proves
that people are capable of having
subjective religious experiences.
Right.
It doesn't definitively proved that
there's anything outside of that.
So Young Carl Young for example,
most of the time he didn't talk about God.
He talked about the God image,
which is not the same thing because you
could have a god image that was even
evolutionarily instantiated without that
necessarily being rep related to any
transcendent being beyond the image.
Right?
So who knows,
who knows?
Um,
again,
I think it depends on what you're
willing to accept as proof.
Now the proof,
the it's beyond question that could,
people can have life changing
religious experiences.
Another example of that is that the best
treatment for alcoholism is religious
conversion.
It's well documented in the literature
and I studied alcoholism for a long time.
So one of the cures that
sticks is religious conversion
and the 12 step programs
essentially attempt to
instantiate religious conversion.
And it's hard to document their success
because they succeed for the people who
stick with it.
But that's not a very good measure.
Right?
It's sort of,
it's sort of self evident that they
work for the people who stick with it.
I'm not cynical about about
alcoholics anonymous or anything,
but we don't have good data on,
on outcome.
But there is good data
showing that religious
transformation is a good cure for
alcoholism.
So,
and that's an interesting phenomena to um,
it's too complicated.
They're probably can't.
Okay,
I'll try.
I'll try this for a second.
So here's how I think a
religious conversion might work.
So imagine you've got the
left hemisphere and it's,
it's the place where your
habitual interpretations reside.
So I can give you a quick example of this.
So this Guy Arama Shawn Ryan,
who's a neuro physiologist or a,
I think that's his,
that's his field of study.
I think he's at Ucla.
He studied people who had neglect.
And neglect is a very,
very bizarre phenomenon.
So if you have a stroke that
damages your right parietal lobe,
you'll lose the left part of your being,
not just your body.
It's really weird.
It's like,
so for example,
if you have a right parietal
stroke and you look at a clock,
you only see you only,
only half the clock exists for you.
It's not like you only see half the clock.
It's weirder than that.
It's that there's only the
right side of the clock.
There's only the right side of you.
There's only the right side of my body.
I don't know that this exists.
And so sometimes people
with right parietal damage,
we'll,
we'll wake up after the stroke and
grabbed their left arm and throw it out of
bed and or their leg and throw it
out of bed because it's not theirs.
And then of course they fall out of bed,
which is quite a shock to them.
So and so,
and they'll only eat half
the food on the plate.
Nobody can really understand
this phenomenal logically,
right?
Because we can't Magine
what that must be like.
I think it must be like,
you know how you know
there's things behind you,
but you don't not see them.
They're just not there.
It's not like it's black or anything,
or there's a space,
it's just not there.
And so I think what happens is the not
there extends to three quarters of the
field instead of half the field.
That's a guess.
Anyway,
so Ramesh,
now,
the funny thing about people with
neglect is that if you tell them,
if you point it out,
you say,
well,
I noticed that you're not
moving your left foot today.
They'll say,
well,
it's,
it's arthritic.
And I can't move it and say,
well,
why don't you just try to move it?
So no,
look,
doctor already told you it's in too
much pain to move it working fine this
morning and that can be
months after the the accident.
So it's a denial and people
thought actually that that
was trauma induced denial
for a long time before they figured it
out was actually a consequence of the
neurophysiological damage.
Now Rama Shondra and found that if
you irrigated the contralateral ear,
say now if you pour cold
water in someone's ear,
it upsets their vestibular system and
their eyes will move back and forth like
this.
You can try that at a party if you want.
And
anyways,
Ramachandran was testing
vestibular function on these
patients and he irrigated
the right ear with cold
water and they woke up.
And maybe what happened was
that that was shocking enough.
So imagine the networks in
the right hemisphere were
degraded but not completely
gone and they needed a really high
threshold of activation to snap into
function.
So here's an example of that.
If you have Parkinson's disease managing,
you're frozen there.
Okay.
And I throw a ball at you,
you'll go like this and catch it,
but you can't throw it back.
So you can,
the stimulus is enough.
That's enough to push you past threshold.
But you can't do it voluntarily.
Now if you have Parkinson's,
like right to the nth degree,
you won't even be able to catch it.
But there's a stage where
you could still do that.
There's a great case study where
this grandpa was in a wheelchair,
he had Parkinson's and his young grandson
was playing out on the dock and fell
in the water and started to drown
and he got out of his wheelchair,
went into the ocean,
rescued him,
brought him onto the beach,
sat back down in his wheelchair
and was paralyzed again.
So that was enough.
So you can imagine there
was enough network left.
So if the emotional tension became high
enough that the degraded circuits could
still function.
So,
okay,
so back to remise Shondra
so you irrigate the year,
all of a sudden the right
hemisphere connections flash,
the remainders managed to
connect and the person goes,
oh my God,
I've had a terrible stroke.
I've lost the left side of my body.
They're crying.
They're like completely catastrophic.
Lee overwhelmed by it.
And then 20 minutes later the they
effects wear off and they snap back in and
now they,
they've lost her left side again.
They don't remember it.
And so what seems to happen is that
the right hemisphere is collecting a
normalist information.
That's what it does.
That's what it does when you're dreaming,
it's,
it's representing that
anomalous information in
image form and sort of slowly
passing it to the left hemisphere
so it doesn't overwhelm it.
And maybe if it gets overwhelming,
you wake up and you're afraid and you
tell someone about the dream that helps
you figure out what it was.
But anyways,
so that the right hemisphere is always
trying to tap the left hemisphere into
transformation,
right?
So now imagine that that can
happen a little bit or a lot.
So maybe you're just ignoring a
little bit of anomalous information.
You just have some mildly
frightening dreams.
Or maybe you've just stacked up a whole
bunch of things that you're ignoring.
And there's some major league monsters
that you haven't contended with.
Maybe there's situations where the right
hemisphere is stored up enough counter
enough of a counter hypothesis,
let's say,
about how the world
works make making sense.
Out of all those things that you've
ignored that one day it just goes snap and
you're a new personality and maybe
the new personality isn't addicted.
So it's something like
it's something like that.
I think.